- Good morning, Believe Nation!
Today's message is start small.
Over to you, John Williams.
(rooster cawing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- First work that I did in
the Hollywood Film Studios
was as a pianist.
In the old Columbia Studios
where they had a contract orchestra,
there was an opening position for piano
which I auditioned for,
and I was hired by the then
music director Morris Stoloff,
who the young people will not remember.
So, that meant that every
day, Monday through Friday,
four or five days a week,
I sat in the orchestra at Columbia Studios
playing under Mr. Stoloff's direction
and watching him underscore
films about westerns
or love stories or scary
films or comedies or whatever
and had a first hand view
as an orchestra member
of how this process of creating
and fitting music to film went,
and two or three years into my
time in the orchestra there,
the same gentleman said,
"Would you prepare the music
"for one scene for next week's recording?"
So I did one scene for
next week's recording
and apparently worked out well enough
that he said in two weeks,
"Would you do two scenes for us?
"We're a little short this
week, maybe three a week later."
So it was a series of steps or
increments if you like to say
I progressed from the piano bench
of sitting in the orchestra
and playing the piano
to a young man sitting not
far from the music library
writing the music for
next Tuesday's recording.
- I think it's really
important for entrepreneurs
that you have a big
vision but start small.
You have a big vision but you start small.
And a lot of entrepreneurs
have a hard time doing this.
You've got the two types of people,
the first are the people who think big
and only want to act big.
You're the dreamers,
you're the non-conformists,
you have this big vision
for how you want to change the world
and what your role in it is going to be,
how you're going to be the next Steve Jobs
and take a dent out of the universe.
I love it but you have
to do something, right?
And so many of those entrepreneurs
just have these ideas
and then they get frustrated
'cause they never get their big break
because they don't want
to take small steps,
they want to take giant leaps forward
where you need to understand
that to take the giant leap forward
you have to start with the smallest step.
And a lot of times people see
that as being beneath them.
Well, I don't want to do
that little tiny thing,
I'm a big dreamer, I'm a visionary,
I want to take huge, giant steps.
But doing nothing,
which was what most of
these visionaries do,
they do nothing, just sit on your idea,
never gets you to that big, giant step.
You've got to take
small, consistent actions
and what that does is
helps you get better,
it helps you learn the market more,
it helps you improve your skills,
it helps you improve your connections,
helps you create more value.
And then that small step becomes
a slightly less small step
and becomes this even
slightly less small step
and you get bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger.
And if you do that consistently,
you'll look back and say,
"Wow, I took this giant leap forward."
And people will say you
became this overnight success
but really it's because of
years of taking small steps
and slowly making those
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger.
So you need to act.
I love the big visionary thinking,
I absolutely love it.
You're going to take over the world,
have a huge impact, solve
a major problem, I love it
but you have to do something.
Start small.
You want to be the next huge YouTuber,
I love it, amazing, but
you're not going to start
until you get the gear and the lighting
and the microphone and the
set up and all of that.
You're not going to start
till you have an editor
and a producer and all this stuff.
You're not going to get that.
Nobody's going to give that to you.
And if you had it, you would suck
'cause you have no experience or practice.
So it's okay to take out your phone
and start recording like that.
Start, take action, get better.
And those small steps will
lead to the bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger steps.
It's so important.
So many of you are just
lost in your dreams
that you don't do anything.
You've got to do something.
Then there's the other entrepreneurs,
who start small but then
they also think small.
There is no bigger vision.
They stay stuck where they are.
And maybe that's a part time income,
maybe that's even a full time income,
maybe that's even the point
where you've built up to the point
where you can provide opportunities
for other people as well.
You've got a team but your
vision is still limited.
Those people could push to think bigger,
to have a greater impact.
You're great at executing
but you're not great at pushing harder
'cause you're stuck in always
trying to be practical mode.
And so there aren't
that many entrepreneurs
that are a good balance of both
where you have the big vision
but you're willing to grind it out
and do all the small steps.
And so whatever category you fall into,
you could learn from
going to the other side.
The visionary needs to
learn from the hustler
who will grind out every little small step
and that grinder, hustler
could learn from the visionary
in thinking bigger how
to explode their company.
And so the question of the day today is
I'm curious, I want to know from you,
your big vision, number
one, what your big vision is
and two, what the small step
you're going to do today is
to build that business a
little bit further forward.
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Omar Karamat.
Omar, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, I really,
really, really appreciate it
and hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys so much for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Alright, Believe Nation,
for those of you who want
a little more knowledge
on starting small, here
are some extra bonus clips
that I think you'll enjoy.
- Best way to establish
yourself on the internet
is to start small, once again, be humble,
approach one of these blogs,
first of all, you got to make
sure your music is correct
'cause there's a million
niggas online doing music
but once you feel like your
music is truly correct,
stay humble, start small,
go to like some of the smaller blogs
that they don't get as
many hits as the NahRights
but maybe they'll post
your shit if they like it.
You know, shout out to DC to
BC and like Pardon Me Duke
and people like smaller blogs, Perfection.
Maybe if they feeling your shit,
you got a shot, if they put it up,
there's a way better chance
that the big blogs'll pick it up.
Especially after seeing, you know,
if Perfection picks it up,
then maybe DC to BC puts it up and
maybe Pardon Me Duke puts it up.
That is three more smaller blogs
that still have good followings
that are putting your shit up
so the bigger blogs like a
2DopeBoyz might pick it up now.
And then after they pick it up now...
So that's the best way.
Just start, have big dream
and then just start small,
But the internet is not
the end all, be all, man.
It's a lot more to go.
- Many entrepreneurs
fail due to over funding.
So you look, we're in
a beautiful location,
Trattoria el Mulino,
it's a legendary family
in the restauranteur business
and they've been doing this for years.
But if you look at somebody
that decides that they can cook
and they want to work on
grandma's recipe, they'll go out
and they'll get a hundred
thousand dollar loan,
they'll open up a restaurant,
they have no experience doing that,
they'll have a beautiful
place, great staff,
but they didn't sell not one piece of food
in their entire life
and they didn't understand
the operation of the business.
Eight months in, a year
in when they realize
why they don't have any customers,
because they didn't have a
customer base in the beginning.
They have a hundred
thousand dollar loan now
on the business and they haven't
figured out the business.
Then all of a sudden,
they have to close down.
I started off literally
with $800 worth of hats,
and that was the beginning.
- [Azim] What would be
my advice to students
who want to start an
organization like Wipro?
- Yes, sir.
- You know the reality is
you'll have to start small.
Like we started small.
You must have a very clear understanding
of why you want to do it,
and what focus you want to build.
And the focus you want to build
in terms of starting an organization,
is something that must be
deeply passionate inside.
Because you're going to
go through ups and downs.
In many cases you're going to fail.
Certainly in parts of your journey
you're going to have major failures.
So unless you have a very clear commitment
to the focus which you build in terms of
what you want to build successfully,
and have the flexibility
to change that focus
because you've not judged
the market properly.
Markets don't run after you, you know.
You have to run after
what the market demand is,
what the market demand you can create.
But you have to be persistent
and you have to be
prepared to make sacrifices
because you will have to make sacrifices
in the early stages, and
some very major sacrifices.
And most of them will
be financial sacrifices.
Because you won't get cash flows
the way you hoped to get cash flows.
Unless you have a brilliant, genius idea.
Then you'll get cash flows.